on va partir au japon où une publicité
mettant en scène l'une des nouvelles
figures du tennis féminin naomi osaka
est au coeur d'une polémique et ses
stades de qui nous explique pour quelles
raisons l'aomi osaka crée vraiment la
sensation partout où elle passe
victoire à l'us open en 2018 victoire à
melbourne et nouvelle numéro un mondiale
mais c'est une pub pour des pâtes en
version manga la mettant en scène qui a
fait pas mal parler en début de semaine
un internaute l'interpellent au cas où
tu l'aurais pas vu ton un peu blanchi la
marque de nouilles en question rétorque
que cela fait partie de l' usage dans
les mangas d'européaniser les héros et
c'est vrai mais la véritable question
n'est-elle pas quel est le rapport entre
le jeu flamboyant de naomi et des
nouilles à l'eau chaude
la dernière question est assez
anecdotique et la vraie question c'est
pour quelle raison at on eu besoin de
blanchir cette jeune femme elle est
d'origine nippo haïtienne vient de
remporter l'open d'australie
quatre mois après son triomphe à l us
open elle vient tout juste de devenir
numéro un mondial donc ceux qui sont
fans de tennis la connaissent ce n'est
ils connaissent exactement ses origines
ils la connaissent physiquement pour
pourquoi d'après vous est ce que on a eu
un centime alors l'argument était de
dire oui mais dans les mangas on
european israël a cherché le terme exact
en europe et à nice tous les visages peu
importe le rôle leur origine sur ça
assez étonnant bon qu'est ce que vous en
pensez ludivine c'est un scandale
évidemment c'est un scandale qu'elle
était très fière de le faire parce que
je pense qu évidemment elle l'a validée
elle c'est ça qu'il faut mais je ne
comprends pas alors il devait y avoir
pas mal de zéro au chèque qu'elle a
encaissé naomi parce que pour accepter
ça je trouve ça juste scandaleux
oui mais quand bien même mieux il y a
beaucoup de zéros sur le chèque est ce
que il faut s'asseoir sur les landais et
des alinéas s'est dénoué n'importe quand
mais voilà surtout surtout avec le
contexte très compliqué a actuellement
je ne comprends pas d'autant que moi je
comprends encore moins l'argument avancé
dans les mangas en europe et à nice
alors boubou et satan petit coeur dans
dragon ball z on les a pas eues
européaniser pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut
l'expliquer je t'en prie le gros
personnage tout rose dans sa tente petit
coeur qui est ouvert on n'a pas eu
besoin est ce que je vais dire mais je
comprends tu dois te gêne mais c'est
vrai que notre corps
vraiment c'est vraiment fallacieux mais
effectivement la vraie question qui se
pose c'est le fait qu' elle est acceptée
ça parce qu'évidemment le dessin animé
n'est pas né a été validé par le
principal intéressé exacte et en
l'occurrence elles caroline l'argent
enfin vous dire elle a accepté l'argent
c'est une énorme star et c'est une
énorme marque alpin et en quelques
secondes et elle l était pas non plus
poser des questions sur la ressemblance
qui a entre l'as la fille dans le manga
et elle vit sa fille dans le manga ça
pourrait être émis lopez donc dire
qu'ils reconnaissent de tennis s'est pas
non plus extrêmement son sosie donc a
effectivement oui la deuxième fois je
suis d'accord avec toi mon char est
scandaleux parce que parce que le
message qu'ont fait passer du coup il
est il et il est pas bon de l'otan
d'autant que pardonnez moi mais c'est la
numéro un mondiale
c'est une méga star elle peut imposer et
dire voilà ça ne me ressemble pas j'ai
envie que ce personnage me représente
dit rooney si aujourd'hui en
l'occurrence je suis d'origine nippo
haïtienne et je veux mettre en avant mes
origines et j'ai retrouvé l'imposer à
mon avis sans aucun souci il est
forcément j'imagine que la communauté
haïtienne va être pas mal choqué de bain
de tout ça et à côté de ça vu que je
l'aimé déjà pas parce qu'elle avait
battu serena williams alors là mais j'ai
la déco mode c'est bien